let me remind you what I said yesterday
The Parables of Our Lord are based
on everyday
phenomenon practices vocations and real
life experiences meaning the parable may
not be referring to an
actual situation but it will be based on
things that people experience every day
so I may speak of a fictional account a
fictional characters in New York going
to Time Square well Time Square exists
New York exists people do go there but
there are times in which I believe the
Lord is not simply taking examples of
everyday
phenomenon to illustrate a point but
there are times in which he may actually
be referring to actual persons and an
actual situation are you with me there
for example I believe Luke 16 19-31
the rich man Lazarus Abraham that's an
actual situation of an actual
conversation that Jesus would know
because he's aware of the realm of the
Dead where the spirits go to awaiting
the day of judgment you with me there
it's not a coincidence that these two
pericopes are
found within close vicinity of the other
what do I mean you ready
now I'm going to show you what the word
is for
Mercy tell me if this is a coincidence
okay so I want to now Hammer this point
because the Greek made it even clearer
in my mind the English is just as good
so don't worry about it and he also told
this Parable to some people who trusted
in themselves that they're righteous and
viewed others with contempt keep that in
mind people who trust in themselves and
thought they're righteous and condemned
others that they didn't think were good
enough two men went up to the temple to
pray one a Pharisee the other tax
collector now if you don't know the
historical background and Luke 19 will
confirm it to be a Jewish tax collector
was one of the worst occupations you
could have why because you were working
for the Pagan overlords who had taken
over the land of Israel and taxing your
people people getting rich off of your
people and fattening the pocketbooks of
the pagans that was considered something
heinous a Jew working for the Romans to
tax his people getting the Romans rich
off of the resources that belong to the
Jews because this is their land and
their mindset now watch here so he gives
an example of the lowest of the low and
he gives the example of the one who's
considered Pious and spiritual highest
of the high Pharisee and tax collector
opposite ends of the spectrum the
Pharisees stood watch
here and was praying these things to
himself God I thank you that I'm not
like other people swindlers unjust
adulterers or even like this tax
collector I fast twice a week now if you
want me to expand on this part twice a
week and how it relates to the diday let
me know right after this I want you to
remember this fast twice a week because
the mentions this I pay TI of all that I
get notice it's not just one tithe I
tithe of all that I get meaning he'll
tithe from his coins he'll tithe from
the flock he'll you get
it look what he says but the tax
collector standing some distance away
was even unwilling to lift up his eyes
to heaven but was beating his chest
saying God I'm going to come back to
this be merciful to me The Sinner this
is where it reinforces the fact you're
supposed to make a connection The Sinner
notice he's broken he realizes he's a
sinner he realizes he's offended God he
acknowledges confesses doesn't hide his
sin right I tell you this man went down
to his house Justified rather than the
other for everyone who exalts himself
will be humbled but he Humes himself
will be exalted now let me give you some
practical
application he acknowledged confess the
sin but that's not enough when you
acknowledge your sin and you confess
your sin you must then turn away from
that sin I tell you this man went now to
his house Justified rather than the
other for everyone who exalts himself
will be humble but he who humbl himself
will be exalted notice he acknowledges
he's a sinner merciful to me The
Sinner confesses acknowledges tax
collector who's looked down upon by
those who think they're righteous loone
behold watch this let's see if you make
the connection Luke 19
1-10 Luke 19
1-10 give the Father the Son holy spirit
all glory for anything good I do in that
I remain humble
Focus all right and he entered Jericho
and what passing through now
watch and behold there was a man called
by the name zakus he was a chief tax
collector and he was rich so two crimes
he is the chief tax collector the main
guy and he got rich by working for the
Romans taxing his people two
strikes okay please Brethren Focus this
is meat doing it for your benefit two
strikes all right
but he had heard of jesus' reputation
and heard Jesus's
coming and he wants to meet Jesus and
see Jesus but he's too
short too short and zakus was trying to
see who Jesus was and was unable because
of the crowd for he was small in stature
in other words he's a shorty he's a
little if I were to paraphrase
this in using Mar English zakus was a
wee little man he was a he
was one of the elves short right so he
ran on before and climbed up into a
sycamore tree which is a fig mulberry
tree in order to see him for he's about
to pass through that way notice he
didn't let anything hinder him from
reaching Jesus so he went to a tree to
look at him now Look Look what Jesus did
I'm going to make the
connection and when Jesus came to BL he
looked up said to him zakus hurry and
come down for today I must stay at your
house Jesus invited
himself come down I I'm going to stay in
your house what's the connection with
Luke 18 let's see for I will stay at
your house now he hurried and came down
and received him gladly with joy of
course you're welcome to my house now
watch the connection when they saw it
they all began to Grumble saying he has
gone to be the guest of man who's a
sinner
there's that word again two connections
with this Parable zakus is the chief
collector and he is a sinner in the
parable the man is a tax collector who
is a
sinner are you making the
connection let's go deep making the
connection you can see it right in the
parable the tax collector is a sinner in
this event zakus is the chief taxor
and he's a
sinner
right watch
here in the
parable the tax collector is asking God
to be merciful to him and God shows him
mercy and justifies him but who's the
one who comes and visits zakus and
forgives him and justifies him
Jesus now watch but Zak
stopped and said to the
Lord watch how deep it goes said to the
Lord behold half of my possessions Lord
I will give to the poor remember what I
said repentance you don't just
acknowledge your sin and confess you
turn away from them acts of
contrition Penance right
penitent so I'm now going to give half
my wealth to the poor and if I've
extorted any one of anything I'll give
back four times as much so Not only was
he convicted not only did he acknowledge
his sin he turned away and did something
about
it so let me show you how this ties in
with
scripture confession is necessary but
Turning
Away completes your confession and
proves your sincerity does here
what does Paul
say watch here Proverbs 2813 watch here
guys Proverbs 2813 we want to learn how
to live our faith I need to do a lot
more of it here you go he who conceals
his transgressions will not Prosper he
who conceals his concessions will not
Prosper you're not going to get far God
will expose you if you hide and justify
sin may we confess it but he confesses
and forsakes them it's not just
confessing it's making an effort to
forsake
them do what you can to stop them now
some sins are harder than others some
are
very strong in our lives there are
struggles but as long as you're
struggling and wrestling and not
justifying God will show you
Mercy the key is your attitude do you
acknowledge it sin yes do you justify it
no are you wrestling to overcome it yes
but sometimes it gets the best of you
yes God sees that will have mercy on you
what's the key confess forsake then
you'll receive
compassion and what does Paul say acts
2620 Paul is
speaking Paul is speaking but kept
declaring both to those of Damascus I
preach to people in Damascus first also
at Jerusalem
and then throughout all the region of
Juda and even the Gentiles that they
should repent turn to God practicing
Deeds appropriate to
repentance see
it your Deeds Contrition penitent
Penance right there now going back
here the tax collector confesses
acknowledges he's a sinner but then we
see this tax Lector then doing
something not only acknowledging turning
away and making things right he proved
the sincerity of his repentance by his
deeds and that's why Jesus then
says what did Jesus say then
says said to him today salvation has
come to this house because he too is the
son of Abraham for the son of man has
come to seek to save the law so like the
parable you have a tax
collector like the parable this tax
collector acknowledges he's a sinner
he's a sinner
right and when the parable cried out for
mercy God showed him Mercy by justifying
him and yet in this story the one who
comes to zakus the tax collector the one
who visits his home enters his home and
brings salvation to forgive him is Jesus
do you see the
connection what's up ID
killer in other words it is not a
coincidence these two pericopes are
there within close proximity because
even if this is not an actual tax
collector this is what we call
demonstrating a parable in real lifetime
meaning he not only said this Parable he
went about and gave an actual example of
an actual tax collector who actually
repented who was a sinner and whom God
actually forgave to show you they're not
just mere Parables they will be played
out in our
lives but what's the connection with
Christ who is the god that
forgave the chief tax collector a
sinner and showed a mercy Jesus
we got
it
focusing or are you guys are bored with
this
already because I'm going to show you
the words
again even if it's not about zakus the
parable is now seen in real life a real
life situation
demonstrating that these parables are
not simply stories but are meant to
drive the point home that even the worst
of Sinners if they turn will be shown
Mercy but who is the one showing
Mercy notice the connection again the
guest of a man who's a sinner what does
the here say let's look at
it be merciful to me The Sinner right
okay let's look because I'm going to go
I'm going to give you another example
sinner right okay watch
here let's go here
so here we have another example where
Jesus is playing the role of
God playing out God's role in the
parable sorry not supposed to do this
watch
here you understand Jesus is assuming
the role of God in the parable in the
parable you had the Pharisee
self-righteous and in that real event
there are Pharisees what tching Jesus
every step condemning him for sitting
and eating with tax collectors and
sinners that's also Luke 15:1 and2 and
then you have zakus the tax collector
then who is God in the parable who's
assuming the role of God in that Parable
Jesus Luke 19:7 let's see what the word
is
okay with a sinful man right a man who's
a sinner ham to how would you guys
Greeks pronounce it
ham okay ham okay see this right now
look at Luke
18:13 Luke
1813 Luke
1813 when he prays who does he pray to
look all Theos he's praying to the God
he
L me to H say word do you see
it same word let me get you the
links go really deep into this one
to you and your foreign languages dude
H and this came to me yesterday and I
believe it's from the spirit May confirm
it sinner right here's the other link
what what is he h
is it a
coincidence am La coincidence or do you
see that the spirit is deliberating
deliberately moving Luke to place these
there in order for us to see the
connection but who does he pray to oh
Theos the
God and then who answers the prayer and
shows up Jesus
who answers the prayer and shows up
Jesus do you understand the role that
Jesus is
playing and here just in Cas you see
what I'm talking
about do you see the role Jesus is
playing all right right here Luke 151
and2 now all the tax collectors and the
Sinners were coming near to him to
listen them and both the Pharisees and
the scribes were grumbling saying this
man received Sinners and eats with them
okay who Tax Collectors all right
Parable Pharisee tax collector tax
collector
sinner so he prays to oos now when an
actual tax collector is
Forgiven notice he
says to
Jesus I will give to the poor
half my wealth and I'll repay anyone of
extorted up to four times as much and
the people are wondering why is he
visiting the sinner so in this miracle
zakus is the tax collector in the
parable the people who are complaining
whining would include the Pharisees so
then what role does this leave for Jesus
to play because in the parable it's a
Pharisee a tax collector and God what
role is Jesus assuming in the parable
when he goes to the man's house and
forgives him and brings him
salvation what role is he assuming even
if it's not an actual situation of an
actual tax collector
praying still what role is Jesus
arrogating to himself when he goes to a
tax collector whom the Pharisees call a
sinner and forgives him and saves him
you got it he's showing you he is the
god
whom you cry out to and who will answer
you if you humble yourself and forgive
you got it but the tax collector is
praying to O Theos the
God now let's go a little
deeper here's what's beautiful about
scripture and the words of Our
Lord the words have
multiple levels of meaning
multi-layered M
multivalent the word to use he says
today salvation has come to your house
okay in one sense what he means is today
I came to save you I've brought you
salvation for son of man has come to
seek and save the lost that's one sense
right that's one level but another level
Jesus himself is salvation itself in the
flesh so he is the INF fleshman the
physical bent of Salvation so salvation
literally physically entered his house
because Jesus's name Yeshua means yahwah
is salvation so here's salvation walking
as a man here's salvation who became
flesh here's salvation in a physical
body so salvation is a man coming to his
house why well let's see because I know
you guys are all Skeptics you know are
just just the way you are the word name
Jesus what's the name Jesus mean Luke
199 so don't mind if I spend the rest of
the session on this right because I'll
do a part
two right here for the rest of you
you're
amazing Luke 199 when we look at the
word
Yus
Yus what does it mean
the Greek form of Joshua Jesus Son of
Eleazar Jesus her name Jesus what does
it mean derived from the Hebrew name the
four letters Hebrew consonants Tetra
Graton he W he right Yahweh and from
Yasha yes yahushua which is combination
of yud wah right the name of God Yasha
so what does it mean the Hebrew origin
of the name Jesus meaning Yahweh is
salvation
the name signifies Yahweh is salvation
or Yahweh
saves so here you have literally
salvation In the Flesh salvation who
became flesh salvation who became a man
salvation entering into his
house right why do you think the angel
tells Joseph the reason why you will
call him Jesus is because he comes to
save his people from their
sins so when Jesus says salvation has
come to your house literally he did that
is Jehovah he is salvation who's now
entering as a man with a physical
body so salvation enters to bring
Salvation it's both